musicien n'est donc pas adopté passons à
l'article premier 1 j'ai une demande de
prise de parole madame Laurence Muller
Brown
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues en tant que sénatrice
alsacienne je ne peux que regretter les
décisions prises depuis une dizaine
d'années concernant
les centrales nucléaires et partout
particulièrement celle de Fessenheim qui
aurait pu être maintenu si notamment
nous n'avions pas fait le choix de
sacrifier la souveraineté énergétique
française aux intérêts économiques et
politiques de nos voisins allemands les
deux réacteurs étaient en effet jugés
par l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire parmi
les meilleurs du parc nucléaire français
tant au plan de la sûreté qu'au plan
environnemental je rappelle que 700
millions d'euros ont été investis dans
la centrale peu de temps avant la ferme
faire la fermeture pardon pour la
maintenir au plus haut niveau et qu'elle
comptait 3000 emplois directs et
indirects pour compenser les pertes
d'activité et d'emploi et rendent cette
décision acceptable auprès des habitants
et des élus locaux un projet
franco-allemand est sorti du chapeau
dans l'urgence une société d'économie
mixte a été lancée sans anticipation ce
ni réflexion et ses soldés par un échec
elle a été dissoute sans avoir mené un
seul projet et après avoir coûté un
million d'euros
enfin les projets de reconversion du
site qui ont été annoncés dont le fameux
Technocentre d'EDF et pour lesquels le
président de la République a promis 20
millions d'euros dans son discours à
Belfort le 18 r février 2022 sont restés
bloqués au stade de l'affichage qu'en
est-il madame la ministre au moment où
vous envisagez la fermeture d'autres
sites nucléaires le cas de Fessenheim a
de quoi nous inquiéter des élus locaux
n'ont pas été écoutées les habitants ont
été méprisés et leurs promesses n'ont
pas été honorées alors je me félicite
que le texte du Sénat s'inscrivent enfin
dans une stratégie globale avec des
perspectives de planification
afin de ne pas reproduire de telles
décisions brutales incohérente et contre
les intérêts des territoires merci
chers collègues Monsieur François
bonhomme
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur on peut toujours dire qu'il
ne s'agit par ce texte que de
débroussailler le terrain administratif
et juridique en attendant une feuille de
route et la relance formelle du
nucléaire avec des centrales de
nouvelles générations et la
reconstitution d'un parc performant mais
mon analyse vous avez déjà nous pouvons
dire que à ce stade vous avez participé
à s'aborder notre industrie nucléaire
certes le sabordage a été initié lancé
par François Hollande et le président
public ce point de vue n'a été que le
consommateur mais cette situation
aujourd'hui nous oblige à reconstituer
notre filière nucléaire pour entamer un
problème de reconstructeur de
reconstruction et cela dans la
précipitation car tout cela va être long
coûteux mais nous n'avons pas le choix
la situation et la crise que nous
traversons est bien fait et bien l'effet
de la mise en œuvre des choix des
orientations stratégiques qui ont été
faits il y a plus de 10 ans voilà ce qui
se passe quand les orientations
stratégiques ont été mauvaises et qui
ont prévalu lors de la PPE 2015 et 2019
voilà ce qui se passe quand on se laisse
intimider par le dogmatisme qui
aujourd'hui se heurte à une réalité
douloureuse de la crise énergétique et
qui arrive en fin quand on se intoxiqué
par l'Allemagne dans tous les sens du
terme qui fait la leçon tout en faisant
tourner à plein c'est centrales à
charbon ce texte est la première étape
de revirement que vous avez vous
obstinez encore appelé anticipation et
en accélération comme si c'est d'un
simplement d'un changement de rythme
alors que nous devons prendre une
nouvelle orientation
et vous faites mis de découvrir que la
production d'électricité nucléaire doit
être la colonne vertébrale de notre
modèle énergétique pourtant les
conséquences aujourd'hui sont en grande
partie les conséquences de vos choix du
passé perte de capacité de notre
production énergétique faisant de notre
pays pour la première fois à
l'importateur net d'électricité de nos
voisins européens produite avec du gaz
et du charbon vulnérabilité structurelle
de notre système d'approvisionnement
explosion des coûts subis par les
collectivités ménages entreprises
dépenses budgétaires considérables et
malgré tout insuffisante pour amortir le
choc inflationniste dégradation de notre
solde commercial et vous avez
l'impudence Madame le Ministre de vous
féliciter du succès de votre plan de
sobriété il faut beaucoup d'estomac pour
dire cela
merci beaucoup monsieur
si Madame le présidente madame les
ministres mes chers collègues devant et
je tiens à reprendre la parole pour
évoquer ce que mes collègues ont évoqué
par ailleurs devant le choix crucial
d'avenir que constitue la création la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires qui est une question de choix
de société un débat public réel s'impose
avec la vraie question de du choix du
nucléaire et pas seulement des futurs
installations sur certains sites
prédestinés donc ce grand débat à la
mesure de ce que représente ce choix
stratégique et politique cela reste pour
moi le premier impératif je voudrais
rappeler que les problématiques posées
par les réacteurs actuels ne sont
toujours pas résolus après plusieurs
dizaines d'années de fonctionnement en
premier on l'a dit les déchets
radioactifs toujours stockés en surface
et proche de la saturation en attente
d'un stockage de longue durée à Bures
s'ajoute le réchauffement climatique
cela a été évoqué avec le besoin d'eau
le ce que nous subissons actuellement
stress diminution des quantités d'eau et
fermetures de certaines centrales comme
celle de Golfech sur la Garonne or il
faut de l'eau c'est un impératif absolu
pour refroidir une centrale et enfin le
risque ultime d'accident qui est
toujours réel toujours possible et si on
peut être reconnaissant à EDF à la SN à
l'IRSN de la bonne gestion de la sûreté
nucléaire nous ne sommes à l'abri de
rien on peut le mesurer au vu de
l'actualité à bien des écarts
préoccupantes s'agissant à la fois de
géopolitique mais aussi d'événements
extrêmes amenés à se multiplier donc je
rappelle que nous devons dans ce choix
associer les Français cela me paraît
absolument nécessaire merci
merci chers collègues Monsieur Jacques
vernique oui merci madame la Présidente
Fessenheim aurait été exécuté c'est
l'expression que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure alors à tous ceux qui répètent
en boucle que la fermeture de Fessenheim
aurait été une terrible erreur à tentant
gravement à souveraineté énergétique je
voudrais juste leur rappeler quelques
éléments ces deux réacteurs n'étaient
manifestement pas en mesure de passer
leur quatrième visite décennale qui
aurait dû intervenir en 2020 pour l'un
et en 2022 pour l'autre l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire c'est pas moi c'est
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire avait
imposé en 2012 la mise en place de
diesel d'ultime secours pour 2018 EDF
avait commencé mais a pris beaucoup de
retard la SN a donc accordé un délai
supplémentaire mais sous prétexte de
fermeture de la centrale EDF a refusé
cette prescription le renforcement du
radier rend séparant les réacteurs de la
nappe freddique avait été très
insuffisant cette amélioration
permettait de sentir la traversée du
corium mais pas de l'arrêter rappelons
que l'épaisseur du radier avant
Fukushima était de 1m20 tandis que pour
la moyenne des autres centrales il est
de 4 mètres et pour Fukushima du 8
mètres l'ASN compte tenu d'un éruption
d'une amélioration même limité à
autoriser la poursuite de l'exploitation
jusqu'à la fin de la vie des trois mais
ça n'aurait pas été le cas pour la
visite décennale 4 enfin la
falsification aux ateliers du Creusot
pour faire passer des aciers non
conformes on se rappelle des fameux
dossiers barrés à toucher de nombreux
centrales à Fessenheim la virole qu'il
avait fallu remplacer sur le générateur
de vapeur 335 qui a quand même provoqué
666 jours d'arrêt était elle-même encore
incorrecte cela avait amené l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire à l'autoriser à
titre transitoire le fonctionnement du
réacteur 2 qu'en mode dégradé et
seulement pour la V3 encore une fois la
vie des quatre n'aurait pas pu passer
ces deux réacteurs détenaient le triste
record du nombre d'incidents sur
l'ensemble des centrales françaises leur
production s'avérait particulièrement
intermittente en clair ils étaient en
fin de vie et par pragmatisme les
investissements pour se hisser au niveau
requis de la vedette n'avait pas été
jugé possible merci Monsieur Fabien gay
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues bon dans ce
titre premier on avait déposé deux trois
amendements qui ont été déclarés et
recevables sur la question du statut des
salariés parce que notre collègue
centriste a eu raison tout à l'heure si
on donne un signal clair qu'on veut
refaire du nucléaire il va falloir de
l'attractivité pour attirer les talents
et oui et il va falloir construire les
filières formations et pour l'instant le
signal qu'on envoyait depuis 10 ans
c'est à nos meilleurs ingénieurs à nos
meilleures techniciens nos meilleurs
soudeurs venez plus dans le nucléaire on
en fabriquera plus et un des éléments
d'attractivité et je sais qu'on peut
avoir un débat entre nous c'est aussi le
statut et c'est aussi le statut
aujourd'hui de la sous-traitance parce
qu'une des questions du retard de le
père de Flamanville pas les procédures
administratives c'est la construction et
quand on discute
avec les ingénieurs avec les syndicats
et y compris avec des responsables d'EDF
ils nous disent que la question la
sous-traitance elle est posée en grand
et donc là je sais que vous et vertuez à
casser les statues on vous l'avait dit
par exemple en 2018 sur les cheminots
vous allez avoir un problème ça coûtera
plus cher et il y aura personne qui
voudra venir discuter à Monsieur farando
aujourd'hui il vous dira que les
concours de recrutement sont ouverts il
y a peu de candidats la RATP pareil
discutez avec Monsieur Castex il vient
d'ailleurs donner une belle conférence
de presse 1000 démissions l'an dernier
ben voilà un des trucs de attractivité
c'est la question du statut parce qu'on
paye moins cher mais oui il y a de la
sécurité sur du long terme et donc de ne
pas vouloir parler de cette question de
la formation et du statut des salariés
de plein droit comme celui des
sous-traitants va poser problème et vous
ne relancerez pas du nucléaire
lourd sans salariés extrêmement bien
formé et sous statut je vous remercie
madame la Présidente merci Monsieur
Daniel salmon
merci madame la Présidente bon je sais
la mode est souvent aujourd'hui à la
réécriture de l'histoire c'est pour ça
que je vais prendre quelques instants
pour vous faire une petite histoire du
nucléaire français tout simplement on
décide de faire un parc nucléaire dans
les années 70 massif on a comme
hypothèse que on va consommer 1000
térawattheure d'électricité en l'an 2000
donc on y va
fortement il s'avère que et bien non on
ne va pas du tout chercher 1000 Tera
water mais il faut quand même entretenir
cette filière nucléaire française donc
on continue de construire le dernier
réacteur est construit et va être livré
en 2002 c'est si beau
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de tout ce surplus
d'énergie et bien écoutez on le vend à
perte à l'Europe c'est le contribuable
français qui offre de l'énergie à
l'Europe très bien je sais bien que vous
êtes partageur de ce côté-ci donc tout
va bien ensuite on nous dit il y a eu
une grande faille il y a plus nucléaire
du tout qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire dès 1989 on commence à plancher
sur les plans de l'EPR
1989 en 2004 c'est-à-dire 2 ans après si
vous si vous trouvez que c'est très long
2 ans il faut regarder deux ans après si
vous on construit le
Pr de Finlande et trois ans plus tard on
lance le Pr de Flamanville il y a pas eu
trou dans la raquette c'est des femmes
tout ça on raconte des bêtises donc
effectivement la gros le gros ratage
c'est le Pr de Flamanville qui devait
être une tête de série et s'il avait
fonctionné on en aurait multiplié sauf
que dommage il fonctionne pas du tout
donc effectivement on peut refaire
l'histoire réinventer trouver des fautes
ici et là mais il faut regarder un peu
les choses en face je continuerai la
deuxième partie de l'histoire plus tard
merci madame la Présidente d'abord pour
rebondir sur le propos Justin à
l'instant ce qui était oublié de d'être
mentionné dans les dans la discussion
générale par votre groupe il faut faire
la distinction entre EPR et EPR 2 c'est
justement parce que il a été constaté
des plus que les défaillances sur le la
construction de l'EPR sur la
construction même sur le le design de ce
de ce réacteur que les partenaires se
sont engagés sur un autre type de
réacteur le père de simplifier et tout
le monde est d'accord là-dessus
normalement ce serait bien de d'avoir
des propos un peu un petit peu plus
exact dans vos dans vos discussions
après je voudrais dire sur le diagnostic
moi j'ai entendu tout à l'heure monsieur
Fanny et je me dis qu'on a un formidable
levier d'économie en fait sur les
visites décennales puisque les visites
décennales sont prévues ça c'est prévu
dans les textes tous les 10 ans chaque
réacteur fait l'objet d'une visite
décennale pour dire si oui ou non le
réacteur est encore en capacité de
fonctionné pour les 10 années à venir ça
c'est la ça c'est la loi c'est c'est
fixé dans la loi et on nous dit en fait
on sait à l'avance qu'une visite
décennale ne va pas être validée que le
réacteur ne va pas être validé mais on a
une formidable levier d'économie l'IRL
la SN sont finalement des autorités dont
on peut se passer si on vous entend il
faut être un tout petit peu sérieux
justement l'objet d'une visite des
cédale a du sens il faut aller jusqu'au
bout de la démarche et c'est cette
visite qui doit
discerner si les difficultés que vous
avez pointé sont susceptibles de mettre
à l'arrêt au réacteur mais moi j'ai les
voyants les voyants verts j'allais dire
les boules les boules de cristal donc
vous disposez je serais curieux de de
les tester parce que c'est absolument
pas là encore une une vérité en tout cas
scientifiques donc laissons faire les
autorités compétentes il peut y avoir
des des choses à regarder de près mais
laissons faire les autorités compétentes
qui sont payées pour ça
merci Monsieur Ronan Dantec
oui on rêve effectivement d'un débat un
peu structuré avec des vrais chiffres ce
qu'a dit Jacques fernix c'est les
positions de la SN c'est pas de la boule
de cristal la cristal c'est ceux qui
pensent qu'on peut commencer à couler du
béton sur le design de le PR2 alors
qu'on l'a pas encore parce que il y a
quand même ça dans la discussion nous
engageons on veut accélérer sur les
autorisations de travaux sur le génie
civil mais le PR2 ni vous ni moi ne
savait à quoi il ressemble on sait juste
que le père 1 c'est trop cher et ça
marche pas c'est ça la réalité et ça
marche pas mieux enfin Landes où il y en
a encore un à l'arrêt là ces derniers
jours et en Chine il y a déjà de vrai
problème la réalité c'est ce qu'a dit
Henri Proglio mais écoutez Henri Proglio
défenseur d'EDF et du EDF d'avant Henri
Proglio a dit de manière extrêmement
claire tout en étant très très peu
favorable au développement des années le
Pr est une vraie connerie et il a dit
devant l'Assemblée nationale c'est trop
compliqué c'est trop cher ça ne marche
pas c'est ça une partie du débat que
nous avons et le débat nous devons avoir
sur la loi de programmation c'est là
dessus c'est à dire que nous sommes en
train de prendre un risque économique
absolu c'est un parieur c'est la boule
de cristal plus plus sur le fait que
nous n'avons jamais démontré qu'il y a
dans le monde tel qu'il est un seul
retour possible économique sur le prix
du mégot mégawattheure produit par le
PR2 les zones ne s'y trompent pas
puisque les rares pays qui vont dans le
nucléaire achètent russe ou américain
mais n'achète pas le Pr parce que en
plus ils ont lu Proglio ils risquent pas
de l'acheter donc on est dans cette
situation donc vous êtes je suis désolé
mais c'est un vœu absolu la relance du
nucléaire sur ses bases et c'est un
risque de marginalisation de l'économie
française et le débat qu'on aura sur la
loi de programmation c'est ça est-ce que
l'économie française survivra au coût du
mégawater en 2040 produit par ce genre
de machine qui ne marche pas
merci chers collègues alors nous allons
examiner deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune sont
identiques et ce sont des amendements de
suppression le 42 monsieur salmon
merci madame la Présidente la définition
d'une nouvelle stratégie énergétique
nationale du nucléaire n'a pas sa place
dans ce texte de loi ce texte ne porte
pas sur la place du nucléaire dans le
mix énergétique et c'est la future loi
quinquennale de programmation sur
l'énergie et le climat qui devra
notamment accès ou non la relance du
programme nucléaire national je ne vous
apprendrai normalement rien sur le sujet
actez ainsi de manière cavalière
unilatérale et antidémocratique le
remplacement de l'objectif de réduction
de 50% d'énergie nucléaire d'ici 2035
par un objectif de maintien à 50% au
moins à l'horizon 2050 pour relancer la
filière nucléaire ou encore
l'introduction d'un objectif de
production d'énergie nucléaire à partir
de matières recyclées 20% d'ici 2030
pour valoriser le cycle de combustion de
combustible n'est pas opportun alors que
le débat public sur les ePER 2 est en
cours et ce jusqu'à fin février et que
la concertation publique sur le mix
énergétique n'a pas encore lieu ces
nouveaux objectifs sont de manière
prématurée toutes les garanties doivent
être apportées pour que ces choix
politiques soient pris dans le respect
du Parlement et de ne concitoyens mais
cela à l'aide d'un n'a pas l'air d'être
facile avec le nucléaire ça ne doit pas
être décidé unilatéralement et en
catimini c'est pourquoi il est demandé
la suppression de cet article merci
merci 54 monsieur manteau
get
ce que je vais dire vaudra pour le 54 le
55 et le 58 je vais pas reprendre ce que
j'ai dit en discussion générale et que
d'autres groupes ont également exprimé
je voudrais
simplement
rappeler l'enjeu
démocratique qui est liée à la à la
possibilité
que les Français s'expriment sur la
question de la politique énergétique de
leur pays c'est une exigence
constitutionnelle puisque elle est
inscrite dans la Charte de
l'environnement depuis 2004 et je pense
que le ce que nous faisons en
introduisant dans ce texte initialement
prévu pour pour les procédures ce que
nous faisons en intégrant une partie du
débat sur la sur la PPE en particulier
n'est pas n'est pas bon ne donne pas une
bonne image de fonctionnement de notre
Parlement aux Français il y a des
consultations ça a été dit qui sont
engagés
consultation sur la stratégie française
énergique Clément consultation également
enquête publique sur les six EPR qui
sont qui sont annoncés
voilà je pense qu'il faut se laisser les
choses se dérouler que nous prenions en
compte le fruit de ces débats de
l'expression des Français qui se seront
positionnés sur ces sujets avant de
légiférer en 2023 comme cela est prévu
voilà on mélange tout je pense pas que
ça soit de nature à clarifier le débat
pourtant fondamental qui concerne qui
concerne les les Français et je redis
que je regrette que le Président de la
République est pris tout seul cette
décision sans considération en
particulier des positions du Parlement à
cet égard voilà j'ai compris qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
aller vite aller vite mais on ne peut
pas le faire n'importe comment et encore
une fois on de tout et c'est pas bon
pour la compréhension des Français on a
besoin d'embarquer les Français sur sur
les questions et les enjeux de ces
politiques énergétiques
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
les deux amendements 42 et 54 qui sont
identiques visent à supprimer l'article
première plusieurs dispositions du code
de l'énergie par coordination avec la
relance nucléaire poursuivi par le
projet de loi et je rappelle que
l'article 1er a constitué un apport
majeur de notre commission pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
contenu de la relance de nucléaire
annoncé c'est notre concomission en
effet souhaité revenir sur les verrous
issus de la loi de transition
énergétique de 2015 d'une part sur
l'objectif des 50 pans pour cent pour
je vous rappelle que si le Sénat n'avait
pas été là
on était à 2025
je le rappelle parce que tout le monde
fait abstraction de de ces événements si
le Sénat n'avait pas été là la PPE
n'était même pas discuté au Parlement
c'est nous c'est votre serviteur mais
c'est puisque c'est vous qui avez voté
les amendements c'est le Sénat qui a été
à l'origine du débat parlementaire sur
la PPE et c'est nous qui avons eu la
capacité de garder au niveau des
discussions dans la CMP je dis quand
même en passant parce que quand
j'entends l'absence de débat
démocratique je pense que là c'est une
belle leçon démocratie que nous avons
ramenée sur le débat parlementaire je le
dis quand même il faut le reconnaître
personne ne le dit je reviens sur
l'autre objet quand même
il y a eu un travail qui a été fait au
niveau de la commission je parle sous le
contrôle de notre président de la
commission des affaires économiques il y
a eu un travail transpartisan qui a été
réalisé
et ce rapport qu'est-ce qu'il dit il dit
relance de nucléaire et il dit nécessité
aussi d'avoir un couplage une réflexion
nucléaire hydrogène donc je le dis parce
que quand on revient sur le 50% et ça a
été dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui et madame la ministre vous
avez dit vous-même
aujourd'hui on est encore à 70%
d'énergie qui proviennent du nucléaire
donc comment voulez-vous relancer
[Musique]
une capacité de production pour notre
pays au niveau de l'énergie pilotable si
vous n'avez une affirmez pas
effectivement ces choses donc c'est un
avis défavorable sur l'amendement 42 et
oui alors je veux redire que
mathématiquement et ça c'est les
scénarios RTE même en construisant 14
réacteurs nucléaires à horizon 2050 je
me place horizon 2050 dans le meilleur
des scénarios ça a été rappelé et c'est
les mathématiques c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment on peut se faire plaisir
politiquement mais il y a quand même la
réalité physique qui nous rattrape le
maximum de la part du nucléaire c'est
50%. je le rappelle dans ces scénarios
de RTE donc ça doit nous faire réfléchir
collectivement par rapport à la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
qui est à venir pour rebondir sur
d'abord juste pour répondre très
rapidement à Madame la signatrice qui
posait une question sur le Technocentre
d'EDF je veux juste vous rappeler
qu'effectivement ce projet n'est pas du
tout à l'arrêt puisque EDF doit nous
présenter le programme l'aide est prévue
elle est réservée dans le cadre du plan
de relance elle est bien financée et des
projets industriels sont en cours de
finalisation sur le site de fenestenheim
et Monsieur gay sur la formation vous le
savez il y a un le premier programme qui
a été je rappelle que le premier
programme de lancer par mes sphères
auquel nous faisons tous référence 56
réacteurs a été construit par le monde
industriel qui sauf erreur n'était pas
sous statut sur la partie construction
génie civile cuve pièce diverses
tuyauterie etc n'oublions pas ce détail
donc en fait on a su faire son statut
voilà ce qui n'enlève rien à la question
du statut mais on a su le faire sans
statut pour une grosse partie des
constructeurs ce qui est intéressant
c'est quelle attractivité quelle
formation comment on fait évoluer les
filières et c'est un point qui est une
un des facteurs clés de succès
potentiels ou pas ou des ou des d'échecs
du programme nouveau nucléaire et je
vous rejoins sur ça
voilà et sur monsieur salmon vous
demandiez
pour enfin nous avons un voilà je vous
au top un EPR qui n'a pas au rendez-vous
exactement et Monsieur Dantec de ce
qu'il devait être je rappelle et ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont les que
vous avez interrogé dans le cadre de la
mission d'enquête qui indique pour avoir
un programme industriel il faut
plusieurs réacteurs
plusieurs réacteurs et c'est très
exactement ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui c'est plusieurs réacteurs
pour avoir un effet effectivement de
convergence et pour écraser les coudes
développement et avoir cette
standardisation et aujourd'hui ce qui
est demandé et ce que fait le nouveau
patron de d'EDF mais avec ses équipes
évidemment c'est de faire un retour
d'expérience des éléments qui ont pu
faire déraper Flamanville pour
faire en sorte de les intégrer dans le
nouveau programme est-ce qu'il faut
simplifier est-ce que le design n'a pas
été ou est-ce que le GO pour la
construction est et la partie maîtrise
d'ouvrage et maîtrise d'oeuf pardon
maîtrise d'oeuvre n'a pas démarré trop
vite par rapport à un design qui n'était
pas terminé ce sont autant de très
bonnes questions sur lequel les
industriels et c'est leur responsabilité
vont pouvoir nous répondre et nous
proposer des facteurs correctifs c'est
pas le premier programme industriel
qu'on réussit le nucléaire je rappelle
qu'on a fait le TGV je rappelle qu'on a
fait on pourra s'accorder sur le CONCOR
s'il était utile ou pas mais ce sont des
programmes et des réalisations
industrielles exceptionnelles qu'on a
porté et avec efficacité et qu'on
continue à porter dans d'autres filières
donc voilà maintenant il faut prendre
les bons moyens pour faire pour revenir
maintenant à cet amendement deux choses
moi je ne reviendrai pas sur la
suppression du plafond de 63 gigawatts
puisque effectivement nous travaillons à
préparer
une proposition de relance du programme
nucléaire nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui
en capacité ça sera le propos de la PPE
de fixer le plafond mais si
effectivement il faut envoyer un signal
à cette filière en voyant le en disant
c'est une question qui est posée la
position du gouvernement elle est très
claire c'est d'augmenter
la comment dire la part de nucléaire en
valeur absolue dans notre mix
énergétique s'il s'agit maintenant de
dire quelle est la proportion ça c'est
une discussion qui suppose d'inviter les
énergies renouvelables à la table et
c'est parce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
et donc par rapport à vos amendements
et je rejoins votre atamisme monsieur le
sénateur montoger que la PPE c'est une
discussion qui doit prendre en compte
l'ensemble des éléments quel
consommation qu'elle baisse de
consommation en cible quelle
augmentation de production des énergies
renouvelables qu'elle augmentation des
énergies nu avec probablement différents
scénarios possibles sur lesquels vous
vous positionnerez et sur lequel nous
ferons des propositions très claires
mais d'ici là je c'est une demande de
retrait au profit de l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui enlèvera enfin laissera
le plafond qui a été enlevé par la
commission
développant durable ou à faire
économique enfin à faire économique
pardon ne reviendra pas sur ce plafond
mais effectivement proposera d'ajuster
l'objectif en tenant compte de la
diversification du mix électrique afin
de dire que nous avons besoin de deux
jambes une jambe énergie renouvelable
une jambe nucléaire c'est le message que
nous envoyons aux deux filières et le
pourcentage ça sera à la PPE de le
définir ainsi que les valeurs absolues
de production énergétique et puissance
que nous souhaitons avoir dans les 10
filières les différentes filières
technologiques donc demande de retrait
au profil amendement 118 merci Monsieur
Breuillet
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues bon d'abord une
remarque sur votre réponse madame la
ministre Flamanville a dérapé mais les
oper2 ça ira bien il suffit d'y croire
j'espère aussi d'y travailler mais
malgré tout il y a un peu de croyance
dans cette idée que le premier repère 2
se portera bien quand le premier EPM
n'est toujours pas en fonction mais
madame la ministre je voulais vous
interroger vous venez donner votre
demande de retrait de ces deux
amendements et je vous avoue que vous
m'avez perdu vous dites ce texte ne doit
pas être l'objet de discussion de la PPE
qui viendra il faut respecter les
procédures démocratiques mais ensuite
vous dites bon d'accord on revient pas
sur les 63 mais quand même on peut
rediscuter du mix énergétique donc soit
on discute de la PPE et de la proportion
du mix énergétique soit on en discute
pas si on en discute pas je pense que
les amendements de nos collègues Salmon
et monte Auger ont toutes leurs places
et que ça permet que ce texte soit
effectivement celui que vous avez
présenté de débattre des procédures
d'accélération et pas du mix énergétique
monsieur Dantec
oui j'avoue que je suis effectivement
moi aussi un peu perdu tout en
rejoignant le rapporteur Daniel grimier
sur le fait que le Sénat a effectivement
investi pour qu'il y a un vrai débat
démocratique et de planification sur la
sur la PPE y compris je rappelle que
Daniel grimier défendait 50 gigawatts
installé en production d'éolien offshore
ce qui est totalement incompatible parce
que certains sur les bancs de LR
proposés en les installant de l'autre
côté du Chanel mais au-delà de ça la PPE
je pense que je la connais un peu
puisqu'il se trouve que c'est le groupe
écolo de l'époque qui a négocié la
dernière nuit avant la présentation de
la loi royale la durée de la PPE avec le
cabinet de Manuel Valls c'était un
élément du deal entre effectivement les
socialistes et les écolos donc je vous
donne des éléments des deals qui ont été
passés à l'époque et que nous avons à
l'époque
et nous avons à l'époque c'est important
passer la PPE de 5 à 10 ans puisque
l'État nous proposait une pépe 5 ans ce
qui était un peu n'importe quoi
puisqu'on est sur des temps de
planification plus longs mais
aujourd'hui la PME elle est quand même
de 10 ans donc là on parle de bécane qui
ne fonctionne pas dans les 10 ans donc
pourquoi on touche à la PPE maintenant
puisque c'est aucune de ces bécanes ne
seront dans les 10 ans les seuls les
seules choses qui peuvent changer la PPE
dans les 10 ans c'est le développement
comme la souligné madame la ministre un
marche forcée des énergies renouvelables
grâce à la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables donc si on change la PPE
c'est uniquement sur la part du
renouvelable puisque dans les 10 ans
c'est la seule part qui peut monter plus
vite donc je ne comprends pas bien la
logique effectivement de cet article je
suis un peu perdu et en quelques
secondes puisque j'adore le débat que
nous avons cet après-midi on est quand
même au niveau industriel dans le seul
cas où le prototype ne marche pas et on
lance la série quand même sans essayer
de voir pourquoi le prototype ne marche
pas attendre qu'il marche un peu avant
de lancer une série
quand même c'est quand même une
nouveauté industrielle comme on en avait
rarement connu c'est quand même un peu
risqué industriellement me semble-t-il
merci madame la Présidente nous on
souhaite revenir au texte initial
c'est-à-dire un texte qui soit un texte
d'accélération qui comporte donc un
certain nombre d'aspects je l'ai déjà
souligné qui soit des aspects à la fois
administratifs et juridique mais quand
on lit quand on lit cet article 1 à
nouveau qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit il nous
dit la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie fait l'objet d'une révision
simplifiée destinée à la mettre en
conformité avec la construction avec les
constructions de réacteurs
électronucléaires ou leur prolongation
poursuivi notamment par cette loi ça
veut dire qu'on est dans la version du
processus ça veut dire que la ppee doit
s'adapter à la loi d'accélération que
l'on va voter ou qu'on votera pas dans
les quelques instants dans les dans les
dans les heures qui vont suivre donc si
on veut véritablement à ce qu'il y ait
un débat serein laissons le débat se
déroulait tous les éléments chacun
pourra se positionner et moi j'ai je
dirais au sens propre comme au sens
figuré beaucoup d'atomes avec Daniel
Grémillet moi je suis je suis je suis un
partisan du développement de la filière
électronucléaire sous certaines
conditions et je regarde Fabien gay
droit dans les yeux parce que je crois
qu'on partage un certain nombre de
points communs là-dessus le nucléaire je
pense personnellement que nous en avons
besoin mais pas de n'importe quel
nucléaire un nucléaire qui soit
nucléaire responsable donc à partir de
ce moment-là donc nous sommes nous pour
le retour à au texte initial tel qu'il
était proposé puis les sons la PPE se
déroulait sereinement et une décondition
de la sérénité justement c'est de ne pas
mettre la pression sur le débat et
d'imposer par ce projet de loi déjà des
décisions qui doivent être prises
ultérieurement je profite des quelques
secondes qui restent pour corriger une
erreur le réacteur finlandais de qui
loue auto 3 est à l'acte actuellement à
l'arrêt non pas pour des questions
nucléaires mais pour des questions de
défaillance au niveau de l'île au
turbine et alternateur donc on aura une
chaufferie à une chaufferie charbon
devant le problème sera le même donc
c'est pas du tout un incident nucléaire
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre vous avez conclu la discussion
générale en disant et en répondant aux
critiques qui émanent de la totalité de
ses bancs sur le fait qu'on prend le
débat enfin que vous nous obliger à
prendre le débat en dépit du bon sens en
nous jurant les grands dieux si je peux
le dire ainsi que tout allait
parfaitement dans le bon ordre et là
vous venez de nous dire qu'il fallait
marcher sur nos deux jambes le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables ce qui
nous renforce dans notre conviction que
peut-être il aurait fallu aborder la PPE
en premier et puis peut-être même qu'il
aurait fallu un texte global qui nous
permette d'examiner
la production énergétique donc dont nous
avons besoin dans sa globalité parce que
la manière dont vous souciez les choses
conduit chacun
je dirais y compris à son corps
défendant
aborder le débat sous un angle presque
idéologique or si nous avons besoin d'un
mix énergétique ça n'est pas d'abord
pour des raisons idéologiques c'est
d'abord pour répondre à des besoins
divers auquel aucune source et aucune
aucun mode de production ne peut
répondre à lui seul et c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin de diversifier donc
vraiment les choses sont ainsi engagées
mais il me semble qu'on commencerait le
débat sous de meilleures hospices si
vous acceptiez d'entendre madame la
ministre qu'il aurait mieux valu prendre
les choses dans un ordre différent merci
merci Monsieur Montauger
merci madame la Présidente
j'écoute attentivement et j'ai
l'impression parfois qu'on se qu'on se
berce de mots je voudrais poser une
question à Madame la Ministre on est
aujourd'hui donc à 63,2 gigawatts
autorisé
qu'elles vont être madame la ministre si
vous les connaissez je pense que vous
avez des informations en ce sens les
effets de grand carénage
qui va qui va conduire effectivement à
l'arrêt de réacteur pour des raisons
techniques sur la base des des demandes
de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire voilà
donc c'est quand même pas neutre par
rapport à la question de ces de ces
amendements je voudrais aussi dire ça a
été ça a été rappelé que la PPE nouvelle
version va arriver très très rapidement
donc ça revient effectivement à donner
un signe à la filière pourquoi pas
et je voudrais attirer votre attention
sur le scénario dit de mix équilibré
comme comme vous l'appelez de RTE le n03
voilà qui prévoit quand même un seuil à
51 gigawatts concernant le nucléaire
avec 27 de nucléaires existants et le
complément à 51 correspondant à du
nucléaire nouveau qui ne sera pas
d'ailleurs couvert intégralement par les
6 plus 8 qui sont qui sont annoncés
aujourd'hui par le par le président donc
voilà on est ce contexte là qui est qui
est pour moi pas très très clair et je
rajoute à cela je terminerai là-dessus
que et on le vit sur nos territoires moi
je suis très très inquiet des
difficultés à planifier le développement
des énergies renouvelables
photovoltaïques et aux liens éolien
terrestre voire méthanisation
on a vraiment des difficultés à
développer tout ça et je rappelle que le
scénario RTE le plus avait la plus forte
proportion de NR prévoit quand même pour
le photovoltaïque une multiplication par
7 et pour l'éolienne terrestre par 2,5
on est on est loin du compte par rapport
à ce qui se dessine et aux difficultés
qu'on rencontre sur le terrain ça pose
la question de l'efficacité de la
planification on vous donnera la parole
si vous voulez plus tard mais il faut
respecter son temps monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues mais vous voyez
madame la ministre dans votre
introduction générale qui a duré 11
minutes 40 secondes vous avez passé 8
minutes à nous expliquer qu'est-ce qu'il
n'y avait pas dans le texte et de quoi
il fallait pas parler et 3 minutes pour
nous dire voilà de quoi il faut parler
et patatras article 1er a ben nous
sommes dans cette contradiction
c'est que votre texte
arrive avant la PPE et ce n'est pas
possible et les amendements présentés
par mes collègues
ils ont justement raison on ne peut pas
débattre
sérieusement sur la question nucléaire
ça a d’avoir défini une stratégie quel
mix électrique etc etc et après on aura
des débats et peut-être des désaccords
et des divergences mais une fois qu'on
aura tranché ça et à l'inverse le
rapporteur a tout à fait raison d'avoir
mis
cela dans l'article 1
parce qu'autrement on débat d'un texte
non mais je comprends non mais je
comprends les deux positions
où on veut accélérer et il y a encore la
fermeture des 12 réacteurs prévus plus
personne ne comprend rien mais madame la
ministre je vous dis la situation dans
laquelle on est ce n'est que votre faute
c'est ne que la façon dont vous avez
voulu prendre ce débat et sur les quatre
amendements notre position parce que je
pense que sur le fond on sera d'accord
émission rapporteur mais on s'abstiendra
sur tous ces amendements parce que de
toute façon vous prenez et vous avez
voulu prendre je ne sais toujours pas
pourquoi le débat dans ce sens là
vous n'allez rien accélérer du tout je
vous le dis
sérieusement sans avoir un débat de fond
je vous remercie je reste comme depuis
le début dans les deux minutes vous êtes
parfait monsieur gay je vais mettre au
bois donc les deux amendements
identiques 42 et 54 qui ont reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ne sont
donc pas adoptées l'amendement 118
présenté par même la ministre pour le
gouvernement
donc c'est tellement vise à revenir sur
la suppression de l'objectif de 50% de
production d'origine nucléaire dans le
mix et l'énergétique qui a été introduit
par la Commission dans ces débats et à
rappeler qu'il que la PPE vise à
diversifier le mix énergétique en visant
un meilleur équilibre entre le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables ils ne
préampe pas comme je l'ai entendu il ne
préampe pas le débat de la PPE il
respecte justement ce qui est la demande
je crois de beaucoup de sénateurs ici de
dire on ne fait pas le débat sur la PPE
j'entends aussi que tout le monde en a
plein la bouche de la concertation du
public sauf qu'aujourd'hui ce que vous
êtes en train de nous demander c'est
d'écraser le débat public le débat
public il est en cours il est en cours
en ce moment il a démarré au mois
d'octobre il y a une convention avec des
jeunes de 18 à 35 ans qui visent à
finaliser ce débat public qui se déroule
maintenant qui se déroule maintenant
auquel d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'entre vous sont invités il y a des
recommandations qui ont été formulées
par la Commission nationale du débat
public que nous appliquons strictement
précisément pour avoir cet exercice au
moment démocratique où nous associons
l'ensemble des Français à la définition
d'un pix énergétique est-ce que vous
êtes en train de nous dire c'est qu'il
faut écraser ce débat ben moi je pense
que c'est pas une bonne idée je ne
foulerai pas la concertation publique
pour
faire la PPE et donc si on le respecte
alors la loi sur la ppee arrive dans les
mois qui viennent elle n'arrive pas
avant la fin du débat public et par
ailleurs et j'ai le regret de le dire
gouverner c'est anticipé
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
je vais pas redire ce que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure sur les amendements
précédents
mais madame Lamy je comprends pas vous
faites une partie du chemin mais
pourquoi vous ne reprenez pas le travail
qui a été fait au niveau de la
commission des affaires économiques qui
va jusqu'au bout qui a le courage
d'aller jusqu'au bout pour deux raisons
vous ne trouverez pas et on le sait tous
ce qu'on a perdu les compétences vous ne
trouverez pas une filière qui va
s'engager au niveau vous ne trouverez
pas de jeunes qui vont s'engager dans
les métiers ou effectivement nous avons
perdu les compétences si vous donnez pas
un signe et surtout une trajectoire non
pas à court terme mais avec une vision
le rôle du gouvernement le rôle des
parlementaires c'est d'avoir une vision
d'avoir une stratégie pour les pays et
je partage que vous avez dit notre
position qui a été votée en commission
des affaires économiques n'est pas
l'hypothèque pas du tout la stratégie de
la PPE pas du tout vous l'avez vous-même
évoqué tout à l'heure objectif 2050 on a
28 réacteurs pour lesquels il y aura des
décisions soit de prolongation si la SN
et si c'est compatible avec la sécurité
soit effectivement de renouvellement et
c'est de tout le questionnement qui aura
au niveau de la PPE mais je vais plus
loin madame la ministre
aujourd'hui on sait tous que la bataille
de l'hydrogène est en train de se jouer
à travers le monde et qu'elle est en
train de se jouer tout près de nous en
Europe notamment avec les Allemands et
on sait tous que si on ne donne pas un
signe notamment sur le nucléaire nous
n'aurons pas de recherche de n'aurons
pas d'innovation d'électrolyseur à haute
température qui apporte les meilleurs
rendements en termes de production
d'hydrogène c'est tous ces enjeux là
qu'on a posé à travers la commission
économique sur les amendements les
articles additionnels que nous avons
présenté donc c'est un avis défavorable
merci Monsieur
le GAT oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre c'est amendement est
complètement en contradiction avec les
propos liminaires que vous avez tenus
tout à l'heure parce que vous nous avez
dit et le compte-rendu fera foi ni la
place du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique sera remis en cause ce n'est
pas un texte de programmation
énergétique voilà ce que vous avez
déclaré tout à l'heure or l'amendement
que vous nous proposez et dans le texte
initial d'ailleurs quand on s'y réfère
le texte initial modifie au moins une
quinzaine de fois le code de l'urbanisme
une dizaine de fois le code dans
l'environnement le Code de la Propriété
le code des impôts le code de
l'expropriation en aucun cas je vous
mets au défi de trouver une modification
du code de l'énergie parce que vous
étiez resté entre guillemets dans votre
couloir de celui d'une feuille de route
et là je suis désolé mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on est en sortie de
route et qu'on est même parti dans le
décor parce que modifier le code de
l'énergie une certaine façon et bien
c'est à travers la suppression de cet
article 5 qui dit quoi il dit réduire la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité à 50% à l'horizon 2035
2035 sinon 12 ans donc on a le temps on
a le temps de modifier il faudra la
modifier il faudra modifier ce code de
l'énergie on a le temps justement de
respecter les débats publics qui sont en
train de se dérouler en ce moment et
nous n'écrasons pas au contraire nous
voulons renforcer le débat public nous
voulons que le débat public se fasse
dans la dans la sérénité et pour que le
débat public se fasse dans la sérénité
et bien ne bordons pas par des
injonctions se débat public en disant
vous pouvez débattre mais on a déjà nous
par le Parlement on a déjà décidé de
modifier la PPE ça me paraît moi et je
lui dis tout à l'heure un déni de
démocratie participative
merci Monsieur longuet
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues franchement je
remercie la Commission et son rapporteur
Daniel gomier d'avoir ouvert enfin d'une
façon qui oblige à la rationalité un
débat qui va durer plusieurs mois et qui
sera Infiné tranchée par le législateur
quel mixte énergétique acceptons-nous ou
plus précisément sur quel principe
doivent se fonder les investissements
qui permettront à notre pays d'avoir de
l'énergie
le débat public par la commission
nationale très bien qui peut croire un
seul instant que de se débat public
puisse rejaillir des
éléments suffisamment précis et
rigoureux je prends l'exemple
l'hydrogène pour décarboner l'industrie
si c'est une priorité ce sont plusieurs
gigawatts qu'il faut installer pour la
seule sidérurgie ou pour par exemple la
chimie et les activités pétrolières si
l'on veut gérer des données et savoir
jusqu'où la consommation de numérique
ira il faut également donner les moyens
d'une électricité parfaitement maitrisée
qui ne peut supporter ni les
intermittences ni les variations de
fréquence par exemple nous avons sur la
mobilité
légère ou sur la mobilité avec les
batteries ou sur la mobilité lourde avec
l'hydrogène des besoins considérables
qu'il faut évaluer nous avons en face de
cela de coûts de CAPEX avec des
technologies qui changent moi je veux
bien qu'un débat public nous disent
qu'elle doit être le mix énergétique lui
permettez-moi de ne pas prendre aux
sérieux ce type de travaux en revanche
en ouvrant aujourd'hui et publiquement
avec le soutien de ceux qui proposent le
texte de la commission et avec l'apport
utile de ceux qui le combattent nous
avons un débat qui obligera les
responsables français compétents
apprendre position et ce que je voudrais
c'est qu'ils prennent position merci sur
des capacités effectives et non pas sur
des sentiments comme ah je vois un
cocktail
ok agréable c'est l'avenir de la France
chers collègues moi je vais vous dire
c'est deux minutes c'est pas deux
minutes de plus et c'est pour tout le
monde parce que tout à l'heure j'ai
laissé monsieur le rapporteur j'ai
laissé monsieur le rapporteur 20
secondes de plus j'ai eu des messages de
droite et de gauche d'ailleurs enfin
quand j'ai droit de gauche un peu
partout pour te dire oui oui si si pour
pour justement demander des temps
supplémentaires donc je vous remercie
d'éviter de dépasser votre temps je
pense qu'en deux minutes tout le monde
c'est passer son message donc merci
beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente je vais donc
enlever 20 secondes que j'offre à
Monsieur Longuet je voulais dire et
redire que ce qu'a voulu faire la
commission des affaires économiques avec
cet article c'est de donner un signal
fort comme l'a dit madame la ministre
pour la relance de la filière nucléaire
ce signal fort il ne peut pas être juste
des mesures techniques il doit être des
mesures techniques pour accompagner la
création de six de paires 2 et pour dire
le nucléaire a de l'avenir dans ce pays
pour les vins pour les 30 prochaines
années puisqu'on s'apprête à faire des
EPR pour se payer
je vous remercie madame la ministre de
dire que la voix choisie parmi la
commission des affaires économiques ne
vient pas se substituer à la PPE que
faisons-nous ici nous disons juste le
50% est obsolète il n'est pas cohérent
avec cette mesure aujourd'hui qu'on nous
propose dans le projet de loi de
création de nouveaux EPM nous le
retirons juste et nous faisons acte que
nous arrêtons la fermeture des 12
réacteurs supplémentaires en disant ça
nous ne préentons pas le débat public
parce que les 50% ils pourront devenir
peut-être 75 et c'est peut-être la
préférence de ce côté-ci du de
l'hémicycle mais ils pourront peut-être
devenir vain et ça sera peut-être la
possibilité ici nous ne préomptons pas
nous simplement nous disons les 50%
c'est obsolète et nous accompagnons les
mesures techniques par une vision
politique
merci alors je mets aux voix donc
l'amendement 118 du gouvernement qui a
même la ministre vous voulez parler
j'entends le débat mais il me semble que
c'est effectivement plutôt un débat qui
tourne autour de la place du nucléaire
je rappelle l'amendement du Gouvernement
qui est précisément en amendement qui
préserve la PPE et qui préserve toutes
les discussions à venir je lis il s'agit
de dire que la programmation plurian
annuelle doit avoir un objectif de
diversification du mix électrique en
visant un meilleur équilibre entre le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
précisément elle pose le débat après
j'entends que ce débat a eu lieu mais ne
prenez pas la partie le gouvernement
alors que nous tenons une ligne très
claire qui effectivement d'aller au bout
du débat public de même que nous tenons
une ligne très claire qui est de dire
que si on nous demande notre avis et ce
que nous proposerons au Parlement est
effectivement une relance de programme
nucléaire et que d'ores et déjà ne nous
y préparons je précise aussi une chose
mais sur le rapporteur on ne vous a pas
attendu pour relancer l'hydrogène bas
carbone les ipci on a passé deux ans à
les négocier avec la commission europ et
on a aujourd'hui 15 projets qui sont
partis sur les électrolyseurs et je peux
vous assurer que ces dossiers sont sur
les rails et qu'ils sont très attractifs
y compris en termes de recrutement de
même que sur la formation ne vous a pas
attendu non plus et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'opinion publique
est en train de bouger puisque
aujourd'hui alors qu'on avait des
difficultés à remplir les sections qui
avaient des spécialités nucléaires dans
les écoles d'ingénieurs aujourd'hui ces
sections sont plus demandées qu'il n'y a
pas de place l'enjeu que nous avons en
matière de formation c'est de descendre
ça jusqu'au compétences de Bac
Professionnel bac professionnel plus
deux ans c'est les compétences de
soudure les compétences
électrotechniciens d'électromécanicien
c'est toutes ces compétences et c'est
l'enjeu de remplacement des personnes
qui seront amenées à partir à la
retraite et d'ailleurs certaines
réformes peuvent nous y aider
merci alors donc je me vois l'amendement
118 du gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils ont
pas adopté amendement 14 me suis
tellement
merci madame le Président il est
nécessaire de rappeler le cadre normatif
dans lequel s'inscrit ce projet de loi
d'accélération du nucléaire nous sommes
lucides nous savons que compte tenu du
retard pris sur l'efficacité énergétique
et sur les renouvelables nous n'allons
pas pouvoir nous passer du nucléaire
existant tout de suite il nous faudra
plusieurs décennies pour nous en
affranchir mais il y a l'urgence à ne
pas relancer le nouveau nucléaire nous
souhaitons ainsi sécuriser le cas de
juridique en vigueur en rappelant que
tout projet de réacteur nucléaire
supplémentaire doit demeurer cohérent
avec le nécessaire mix énergétique ainsi
qu'avec l'obligation de réduction de la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité c'est le débat que nous
avons en ce moment nous ne partageons
pas votre vision qui demeure à l'article
l104 du code de l'énergie aujourd'hui
seule l'exploitant à la possibilité de
demander l'abrogation des autorisations
d'exploiter lorsque le plafond de 63,2
gigawatts et susceptible d'être dépassé
ce plafond a pour objectif uniquement
d'éviter une extension du parc nucléaire
et ne permet pas de remplir les
objectifs de réduction de la part du
nucléaire fixée par la loi ainsi en
dotant le ministère de l'Énergie du
pouvoir de fermeture des centrales
nucléaires nous souhaitons aux éviter de
faire reposer entre les mains exclusives
de l'exploitant la possibilité d'abroger
des autorisations d'exploiter et
garantir le respect des objectifs de
décarbonation du mix et de réduction de
la part du nucléaire ce n'est pas à
l'exploitant de piloter la politique
énergétique française merci
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
s on n'a pas dit la même chose je
parlais des électrolyseurs haute
température et vous m'expliquerez
comment vous en faites sans nucléaire
sur le cet abonnement là je voulais dire
tout simplement c'est pour tirer un
trait sur cette politique d'attribution
du nucléaire que la Commission proposait
d'abroger ce plafonnement a priori de
63,2 gigawatts
si on va dans votre sens
c'est absolument pas souhaitable parce
que la rédaction telle que vous l'avez
rédigé en plus ça pourrait permettre de
remplacer de l'énergie nucléaire
décarbonée par des énergies fossiles
voire et missiles donc la vie
défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement
c'est également un avis défavorable
merci je vais donc mettre au voile à un
moment 14 qui a reçu un avis défavorable
comme celui du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et donc
pas adopté je mets au voile article
premier a qui est pour contre qui
s'abstient et donc adopté article
premier B deux amendements identiques de
suppression le 43 monsieur salmon est
déjà prêt tout à fait je veux gagner du
temps Madame la Présidente c'est
amendement vise à supprimer l'article
premier B a jeté en commission qui acte
la relance du programme nucléaire
français sans respecter le processus
démocratique en violation du principe de
la participation du public nous sommes
assez d'accord il nous en débattons
depuis un moment que ce texte a un côté
décalé et il am